In this video, we introduce “Fruit Salad”
a group game to make class more fun, boost
energy and allow students to get to know each
other better.
Teachers can play the game with kids 8 years
or older and with group size from 8 to 30.
One session can take 5 to 30 minutes and all
you need is a room and some chairs.
Start with all students sitting in a circle
and the student with the most recent birthday
standing in the middle.
Then the student standing asks the questions
that can be answered with yes or no.
Younger children might ask: Do you like vanilla
ice cream?
Or do you like to get up early?
Older players are often more personal like
did you ever kiss anyone?
Did you ever do something that your parents
would not allow?
All students who have answered questions with
yes, get up immediately and try to find a
new chair without speaking their answers out
loud.
They can pick any chairs except their own
or the one right next to them.
While everybody is up, looking for a new seat.
The aim of the player in the middle is to
catch a free chair.
The player who doesn’t catch a chair is
next to stand in the middle and ask a question.
If the player in the middle cannot think of
any spontaneous questions, he simply shouts
“Fruit Salad”!
And all the kids get up and change places.
The game is fast to set up, fun to play and
students love it because we get to know each
other better.
If you are a teacher, please give it a try
and tell us how it works for you.
If you are a student or parent, ask your teacher
to give it a try.